now when you're a kid and your mom or
your dad reads a bedtime story it can
all seem so real right you imagine a
giant Beanstalk reaching up to the sky
and little jack is climbing it you may
have been scared the wolf was gonna huff
and puff and blow your house down
I personally always looked underfoot
bridges for the troll and three Billy
Goats Gruff scary but eventually we're
supposed to grow up and leave the fairy
tales behind but not so with the
nevertrump errs they are still clinging
to their fantasy to a Republican Party
that no longer exists and they think
that if they hate the president enough
then they'll convince others to go along
with their open borders pro-china trade
pro military interventionist outlook now
you may not know these people they have
zero constituency Republicans hate them
Democrats are just using them I'll get
to that in a moment so let me introduce
them to you
the founding member of the fairy tale
party is failed magazine editor Bill
Kristol who famously predicted this in
2003 whatever else you can say about
this war they're just at one point
George Bush is not fighting this like
Vietnam whatever the we don't need to
refight the whole thing a bit now maybe
that's the danger but it's not going to
happen happen from his Martin to be a
two-month war not eight Park Hill he
scoffed at the notion of Donald Trump
winning the presidency the nomination in
2015 this is something going on I gather
he's doing okay in the polls for a while
but he's not gonna be the nominee so
we'll be fine and now he claims to be a
trump mind reader I think he is he sees
bad a bad economic news coming and bad
political news coming and that he's a
demoralized guy hey Bill nineteen year
high for consumer confidence might want
to revise your remarks well in case you
forgot this is a guy who thought a
National Review
columnist could beat Donald Trump in the
spring of 2016
he's gonna do it all at the convention
it was gonna be a big deal well this was
too much even for Mika Brzezinski to
take Bill Kristol
has got to stop sort of I'm trying to
think of a uncrossing sorry well
unfortunately the war peddler didn't
listen he kept playing in this political
land of make-believe
maybe he makes money there and then
there's crystals buddy Brett Stephens
the sullen neocon op-ed writer for The
New York Times now he regularly dishes
out the nastiest vile about the
president and his supporters what we saw
over the last few days is a president
who is either mentally unwell or morally
unfit
maybe both I don't know you have
behavior that is is unprecedented in any
kind of presidential history in the
United States or or frankly elsewhere
but Stevens himself a pillar of of
stability well he's like a little flimsy
balloon he pops the second he gets a
little pinprick on Twitter yesterday a
professor at George Washington
University described me as a bedbug or a
metaphorical bedbug so I wrote him a
personal email I didn't go to Twitter I
also copied his Provost on the note
people are upset about this I want to be
clear I had no intention whatsoever to
get him in any kind of professional
trouble my manager should be aware of
the way in which their people their
professors or journalists interact with
the rest of the world who died made him
a head of human resources what a
goofball hey Brett stop lying if he
didn't want to get the guy in trouble at
work you wouldn't have cc'd the Provost
simple as that and have you ever heard
of this woman her name is Jennifer Rubin
and she's described as a blogger for the
Washington Post now every syllable out
of her mouth is contempt toward
President Trump and many of you watching
and now this woman of meager
accomplishment
us all to be banished all together
banished from public life what we should
be doing is shunning these people
shunning shaming these people is a
statement of moral indignation that
these people are not fit for polite
society we have to collectively in
essence burn down the Republican Party
we have to level them because if there
are survivors if there are people who
weather this storm they will do it again
now her talk of burning it down and
urging that potential survivors be
eliminated and Trump's rhetoric that's
the problem that incites violence it's a
shameful but one of my favorite
characters and the nevertrump nonfiction
series is this fellow named max boot who
kind of bears in the forehead ELISA
uncanny resemblance to Max Headroom
which one's cuter now before Trump got
elected he kind of just seemed like
another goofy neocon huckster whose
calendar was stuck in the year 2004 but
boot claims quote the GOP has suffered a
complete moral and intellectual collapse
well by smearing everyone whose skin
happens to be white who voted for Trump
boot calls him a bunch of white
supremacist what this sorry but kind of
hilarious lot doesn't really understand
is that their fairytale house it's
already burned down in 2008 and in 2012
when they lost the presidency twice to
Obama then Trump comes in and he builds
a new party that drew in people from the
Obama camp voted for him the first time
people hadn't voted for a while and they
recognized that Obama man was just
another globalist who would cash out
once he left office the little people be
damned but the never Trump fantasy I was
thinking about it too it's kind of like
a bad romance novel but within without
any of the hunky characters you just
want it to be over
and that's the angle